schönen guten abend das große experiment
im öffentlichen nahverkehr ist gestartet
seit diesem ersten juni seit heute gilt
das neun euro ticket fahrgäste können
den nahverkehr im juni juli und august
für neun euro im monat nutzen das ist so
günstig wie noch nie die einen sprechen
jetzt schon vom rohrkrepierer andere vom
knaller die das verkehrsministerium sagt
auf twitter mega das können wir uns mal
gerade anschauen
und spricht von 7 millionen verkauften
tickets
ja wie mega genau und ob überhaupt das
werden wir heute abend den minister für
verkehr und digitales fragen volker
wissing und selbstverständlich könnt ihr
ihm eure fragen schicken eure kommentare
am besten per mail oder ihr schreibt es
einfach in die kommentarspalten rein
aber jetzt erstmal guten abend herr
wissing guten abend kurze frage vorab
haben sie das neue euro ticket heute
schon genutzt ich konnte es heute noch
nicht nutzen aber ich werde es nutzen
und ich habe schon als erworben das ist
doch schon mal ein anfang herr wissing
sie bleiben bei uns jemand der das neun
euro ticket nämlich heute schon intensiv
genutzt hat ist unsere reporterin luisa
houben zudem wollen wir schalten nach
magdeburg an den hauptbahnhof heil luisa
du was heute in sachsen-anhalt unterwegs
und erzählen uns mal wie das neun euro
ticket dort ankommt
genau ich bin mittlerweile in magdeburg
am hauptbahnhof angekommen gestartet
habe ich meinen tag aber in halle an der
saale am hauptbahnhof da habe ich mir
natürlich erstmal auch das neue
neurotiker zugelegt am schalter das geht
ja aber auch eigentlich am schalter am
automaten
ich habe am schalter oder online und
dann hatte ich eigentlich den eindruck
da ist genau so viel los wie sonst
pendler auf dem weg zur arbeit und dann
bin ich aber selbst auch eingestiegen
und sein eine s bahn in richtung
wittenberg bis sein braucht man von
halle aus so eine stunde ungefähr und
das ist eine strecke so in richtung
berlin neben die viele oder aber auch
wenn sie an die ostsee wollen ja und der
zug der wurde dann eigentlich immer
voller reis und mein eindruck daran
pendler unterwegs da waren waren
studierende unterwegs und das fand ich
auffällig vor allen dingen auch viele
menschen die auf einem ausflug fahren
deswegen wurden die gänge die kennt ihr
vielleicht darum man sein fahrrad
abstellen muss die wurden immer enger da
war es ganz schön voll und ich bin dann
mit den menschen auch ins gespräch
gekommen habe sie gefragt warum nutzen
sie jetzt also nutzen sie das euro
ticket und vor allen dingen auch warum
und eine auszubilden und eine familie
die haben mir erzählt die sind richtig
richtig halb peters ist das neue euro
ticket denn jetzt gibt weil sonst würden
sie gar nicht bahn fahren wir hören da
mal rein
weniger als 1000 euro pro monat
hersteller für mieter raus sollte mich
ist es echt toll durch den sommer über
günstiger unterwegs sein kann
und wir laufen auch für
unterhalt flix bull fahrer webber der
als günstiger ich habe sonst ein auto ja
aber jetzt für die drei monate werde ich
auf jeden fall nicht nutzen weil bambus
ist einfach kostengünstiger weil jetzt
momentan auch bei den preisen vom sprit
hat das ist unbezahlbar
also luisa was hast du denn alexander
dem
strich recht weit her erzählt uns wie
dein tag war er ja den alexander den wir
gerade gehört haben dass es ja
eigentlich ein beispiel für die leute
die ihr auto stehen lassen das ist ja
auch ein ziel des neurotischen das auto
stehen lassen und stattdessen mit der
bahn fahren und mir eine frau erzählt
sie ist seit 30 jahren nicht mehr bahn
gefahren aber jetzt dankt es dann neun
euro tickets gibt sie der bahn noch mal
eine chance und hofft dass sie damit zur
arbeit fahren kann sie zahlt sonst 150
euro spritkosten unter ist neun euro
natürlich die willst sich bessere
variante also deine eindrücke dass das
positiv aufgenommen wird die decken sich
im wesentlichen mit dem was er aus
anderen teilen deutschlands hören jetzt
könnte es ja aber zettel an pfingsten in
den nächsten tagen auch deutlich voller
werden wie bereitet sich die bahn darauf
vor
ja da habe ich mit einer schaffnerin
heute gesprochen und die sagten sie es
ganz schön froh dass sie an pfingsten
nicht arbeiten muss weil wenn sie heute
schon gesehen hat dass so viele menschen
mit dem fahrrad unterwegs sind dann kann
es tatsächlich passieren dass sie gar
nicht alle mitnehmen kann und leuten
sagen wo es hey ihr müsst die nächste
bahn nehmen oder kommt heute vielleicht
gar nicht mit und da sagt die bahn sie
tut alles was sie kann sie hat alles was
auf die schiene geht setzt sie auf die
schiene aber sie bietet eben auch um
verständnis und um geduld dass es halt
dann doch an der ein oder anderen stelle
haben kann was würde es so sagen ganz
kurz dein fazit nach dem ersten tag
ja also was ich heute erlebt hab ist
durchweg positiv die leute freuen sich
über das neue euro ticket und ich hab
sogar vom einen oder anderen gehört der
überlegt sich jetzt schon was es
eigentlich nach den drei monaten gibt es
dann eine alternative weiter eine
günstigere möglichkeit den nahverkehr zu
nutzen da bedarf es auf jeden fall da
vielen dank louis saha nach magdeburg
und die frage wollen wir nicht will ich
dann jetzt auch gleich verkehrsminister
witzigen stellen der heute bei uns zu
gast es bei zdf heute live ja weswegen
sie hören kommt bis jetzt ganz gut an
und das ganz große chaos was er
teilweise befürchtet wurde das ist heute
morgen ja ausgeblieben wie erleichtert
waren sie da
ich habe mich gefreut dass so viele
menschen begeistern mit begeisterung des
09 euro ticket kaufen und nutzen und ich
hatte vertrauen in die
verkehrsunternehmen und systemisch
bestätigt das hat gut funktioniert das
war sehr gut vorbereitet und sehr gut
organisiert und auch die bahn meldet mir
vor wenigen minuten dass der tag
erfolgreich verlaufen ist jetzt haben
wir viele gesagt das haben wir eben
gehört schade dass es dieses neuen euro
ticket nicht länger geben soll 9 euro
wenn vielleicht langfristig ein bisschen
wenig muss ja auch irgendwie finanziert
werden aber ich kann den x 1 2
kommentare dazu vorlesen auf youtube
schreibt ein user lohnt sich für mich
lieber aber auch in einer großstadt die
auf dem land leben bleiben bei der
infrastruktur wohl weiterhin beim auto
ein anderer schreibt da ich sonst 11
euro für eine tageskarte im hvv zahle
ist es sehr geil auch um die familie zu
besuchen ist es vorteilhaft allerdings
sind in drei monaten die normalen zu
teuren preise zurück und damit auch
keinen grund mehr für mich bahn zu
fahren denken sie dass öffentlicher
nahverkehr auch langfristig günstiger
werden muss das wollen wir besprechen
und evaluieren natürlich ist dieses 9
euro ticket ein super günstiges angebot
das kann man auf dauer so bei dem preis
nicht machen das ist eine besondere
maßnahme mit der wir auf die extrem
hohen preise und die schwierige
situation angesichts des krieges in der
ukraine reagieren wir wollen einen
anreiz zum energiesparen setzen und
natürlich auch bürgerinnen und bürger
entlasten aber klar ist auch dass der
öpnv
sehr attraktiv ist und wir wollen
natürlich auch dieses diese phase
evaluieren und genau zu wissen was
können wir an welcher stelle verbessern
insofern liefert das neun euro ticket
über die drei monate hinaus einen
wichtigen beitrag zur stärkung des öpnv
eins der ziele die sehr verfolgen ist
das eben viel mehr menschen wieder busse
und bahnen nutzen es ist dann zeitlich
vielleicht unglücklich dass heute das
neun euro ticket gestartet ist und auch
gleichzeitig der tank rabatt nein das
ist ja bewusst so gemacht worden weil
der bundesfinanzminister linda hat
gesagt er möchte nicht dass diese hohen
kraftstoffpreise dazu führen dass der
staat
überproportional an steuern verdient
sondern er hat gesagt ich möchte die
bürgerinnen und bürger entlasten bei den
kraftstoffen weil die grundpreise so
hoch sind und dann muss der staat jetzt
nicht
steuermehreinnahmen haben und
gleichzeitig haben wir gesagt wir wollen
aber auch einen anreiz zum
energieeinsparen setzen und dafür dass
neun euro ticket angeboten insofern die
beiden maßnahmen passen sehr gut
zusammen und gehen miteinander einher es
werden diejenigen entlaste die aufs auto
angewiesen sind aber auch diejenigen die
den öpnv nutzen bereit die frage ob dann
vielleicht dieser motivationsanreiz öpnv
zu nutzen
etwas schwächer ist wenn gleichzeitig
auch der tank rabatt gestartet ist das
wurde im vorfeld diskutiert und wir
haben das anders gesehen und die hohen
verkaufszahlen geben uns recht wir haben
sie über sieben millionen euro über
sieben millionen tickets verkauft und
die rückmeldungen die sie bekommen haben
sind ja auch positiv ich hier höre auch
im ländlichen raum übrigens von
bürgerinnen und bürgern die mir sagen
wir werden den omv drei monate
ausprobieren das ist ja nicht so dass in
der fläche keine verbindungen da sind
diese natürlich nicht überall so gut wie
in der stadt aber jetzt mal genau
hinzuschauen was für möglichkeiten habe
ich denn was würde das für mich bedeuten
wenn ich den öpnv nutzer ich probiere
das mal aus schauen wir mal an wie das
im alltag läuft glaube das sind alles
positive effekte und ganz offen gesagt
das ist eine der größten werbekampagnen
für den öpnv in der geschichte des
landes
damit haben sie im prinzip die frage von
walter wobmann auch schon
beantwortet der sagt was empfehlen sie
leuten die auf dem land leben wie können
diese leute das ticket sinnvoll nutzen
zur wahrheit gehört auch dass die
voraussetzungen für eine richtige
stressfreie sage ich mal nutzung des
öpnv unten noch nicht so richtig stimmen
am stichwort pünktlichkeit schwierige
sache bei der bahn schauen wir uns kurz
an
die fernverkehrszüge der deutschen bahn
sind so unpünktlich wie seit jahren
nicht mehr laut konzern kam 2022 gerade
einmal 70 prozent der fernverkehrszüge
künftig an die anderen 30 prozent
verspäteten sich bei der deutschen bahn
bedeutet dass die züge kamen mindestens
sechs minuten zu spät zugausfälle
berücksichtigt die statistik nicht
der konzern wird damit auch 2022 seine
ziele für den fernverkehr verfehlen
eigentlich sollten in diesem jahr
mindestens 80 prozent der
fernverkehrszüge pünktlich ankommen
im regionalverkehr schneidet die bahn
besser ab vergangenes jahr erreichten
nachbarn definition über 90 prozent der
züge pünktlich ihr ziel doch die bahn
warnt wegen der steigenden
passagierzahlen durch das nur ein euro
ticket könnte sich die situation
verschärfen
herr wissing wenn man als pendlerin oder
pendler nicht davon ausgehen kann dass
man pünktlich zur arbeit ankommt dann
ist das ein problem wie wollen sie dem
begegnen also zunächst einmal dieses
problem der pünktlichkeit ergibt sich im
wesentlichen im fernverkehr das hat der
beitrag eben auch gezeigt und das hängt
damit zusammen dass das netz
schlicht und einfach die die intensität
des verkehrs gegenwärtig nur schwer
ertragen kann da werden wir in den
nächsten wochen ein konzept vorlegen die
bahn und ich wie wir das angehen um
unser netz zu einem hochleistungsnetz um
zu arbeiten von der bahn werden hohe
leistungen erwartet bei rekord
passagierzahl und unser netz ist heute
kein hochleistungsnetz das muss sich
ändern und insofern ist ist der auftrag
klar erkannt und es wird wie gesagt auch
ein konzept dazu geben und natürlich ist
es wichtig dass züge pünktlich sind wir
haben aber im nahverkehr eine deutlich
höhere pünktlichkeit und insofern glaube
ich dass das neuen euro ticket gut
geeignet ist um den weg mit dem öpnv zum
arbeitsplatz zu finden sie haben gerade
gesagt stichwort schienennetz gibt es
richtig viel zu tun meine kolleginnen
die wesentlichen punkte noch mal kurz
zusammengefasst die
gründe für die verspätungen volle gleise
marode infrastruktur und zu langsame
digitalisierungsprozess ein beispiel
bisher sind alle gleise in feste
abschnitte unterteilt die immer nur ein
zug befahren darf mit digitaler zog
steuerung können diese schon kürzer und
flexibler werden
mehr züge können so in schnellerer folge
auf dem gleis fahren
trotzdem sagt bahn-chef richard lutz
wenn ich eine störanfällige
infrastruktur digitalisierung bleibt es
eine störanfällige infrastruktur
die angekündigte lösung der bahn alles
neu generalsanierung ab 2024 soll es auf
den zentralen trassen losgehen weichen
leitungen oder signale sollen nicht wie
bisher nacheinander saniert werden
sondern gebündelt
lieber eine große sperrung stadt viele
kleine ist das motto klingt effizient
hat für kundinnen aber temporär ein
nachteil lange sperrungen und viele
ausfälle oder wie die deutsche bahn es
nennt ein tal der tränen bis 2030 soll
dadurch laut der bahn ein
hochleistungsnetz entstehen das eine
verkehrswende möglich macht das wäre
gerade noch rechtzeitig für die bis 2030
geplanten klimaschutzziele
das tal der tränen bei der bahn gehen
sie davon aus dass dieses problem dass
er wirklich so wahnsinnig komplex ist
eigentlich überhaupt in den griff zu
bekommen ist ja wir brauchen ein
hochleistungsnetz und sie ist es in dem
beitrag richtig beschrieben wir brauchen
zum einen digitalisierung aber wir
müssen auch dass die das schienennetz
auf einem qualitativ besseren stand
bringen das hat mit signalisierung zu
tun das hat mit der zahl der weichen zu
tun und dazu werden wir ein konzept
vorlegen und werden dann auch die
sanierungsmaßnahmen entsprechend
ausrichten das ist natürlich richtig
dass wenn man ein netz zum
hochleistungsnetz ausbaut dass das zu
vielen baumaßnahmen führt und
baumaßnahmen beeinträchtigen den betrieb
und führen am ende zu verspätungen
allerdings muss man diese maßnahme jetzt
beherzt angehen wir kommen nicht darum
herum wenn wir so weiter machen wir in
den letzten jahren dann müssen wir uns
mit immer mehr verspätungen abfinden und
das will ich nicht deswegen müssen wir
einmal über diese hürde trüber man das
bereiten wir jetzt vor aber wir werden
das so organisieren dass wir nicht
natürlich alles auf einmal machen
sondern dass wir korridor weise vorgehen
und deswegen das gut mit dem betrieb in
einklang zu bringen sein wird wenngleich
herr lutz recht hat eine so große
sanierung und
ertüchtigung maßnahme führt natürlich
erst einmal zu mehr behinderungen im
verkehr wenn sie das ist wie bei straßen
auch wenn sie eine brücke sanieren dann
müssten leidet der verkehrsfluss nur
wenn sie die brücke nicht sanieren dann
muss sie irgendwann komplett gesperrt
und gesprengt werden so was haben wir im
moment bei lüdenscheid und deswegen ist
es nicht richtig wenn man aus sorge vor
beeinträchtigungen des verkehrs
sanierungen und modernisierungsmaßnahmen
immer in die zukunft verlagert ich kann
heute nicht rückwirkend regieren aber
ich kann das problem jetzt angehen und
ich bin entschlossen das zu tun mir das
sehr einer der kritikpunkte auch am
neuen euro ticket dass gesagt wird das
macht nicht so richtig sinn jetzt mehr
menschen in busse und bahnen zu holen
wenn diese ganzen sanierungsmaßnahmen
anstehen der der schuss könnte er nach
hinten losgehen das sehe ich so nicht
denn es ist nie in diese probleme die
wir bei der bahn haben sind im
wesentlichen die großen korridore für
den fernverkehr und für den güterverkehr
und das neun euro ticket ist ja ein
nahverkehrs ticket und regionalverkehrs
ticket man kann damit in der fläche mit
bussen fahren mit regionalbahnen fahren
und es ist ja nicht so dass wir im
gesamten netz der bahn diese probleme
haben wir haben diese probleme in den
dicht befahrenen haupt korridoren und
das sind nicht die strecken die den für
den öpnv
schwerpunktmäßig genutzt werden insofern
passt das nicht zusammen dass man sagt
wegen der probleme im
hauptnetz im kernnetz
braucht man kann kein euro ticket im
gegenteil wir haben in den in den
strecken im schienenpersonennahverkehr
haben wir kapazitäten haben im
augenblick nur ein passagier auslastung
von 80 prozent im vergleich zu der zeit
vor corona dh da kann mit gleichem
material und gleicher personalstärke
können 20 prozent mehr fahrgäste
befördert werden ich möchte sie bitten
noch eine frage aus dem chat zu
beantworten martin schreibt auf facebook
wird im kabinett oder unter den ländern
ein kostenloser app nv zumindest
diskutiert
das ist nicht finanzierbar denn wir
haben erheblichen bedarf den dänen das
angebot ja ständig zu verbessern zu
optimieren zu uns kommen viele die sagen
wir brauchen mehr angebote in der fläche
und wenn wir auf die ticketeinnahmen
verzichten dann können wir in zukunft ja
nicht mehr angebot finanzieren der bund
zahlt heute schon in diesem jahr über 13
milliarden euro für den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr um den status quo zu
finanzieren und jetzt müssen wir wenn
wir das angebot ausweiten wollen uns ja
mit der frage beschäftigen wo soll das
geld herkommen natürlich ist der öpnv
ist die schiene für uns ein schwerpunkt
aber wir haben viele andere bereiche
auch zu stemmen und wir können nicht
unbegrenzt geld ausgeben denn das müssen
die bürgerinnen und bürger aller wörter
erwirtschaften oder arbeiten hier machen
sich einige ein bisschen sorgen dass das
böse erwachen danach den drei monaten
kommt aaron schreibt drei monaten euro
und dann wird es richtig teuer waren zu
fahren zuckerbrot und peitsche das halte
ich davon ein anderer user schreibt
jetzt findet er dass alle noch richtig
geil bis in drei monaten die preise so
steigen dass sie alles mehr und wieder
hereinholen was sagen sie den leuten das
ist neun euro ticket führt nicht zu
preissteigerungen im normalen tarif denn
wir finanzieren ja von bundesseite die
gesamten ticketkosten für diese 90 für
diese drei monate und die
verkehrsverbünde nehmen zusätzlich noch
die 9 euro ein
insofern es gibt keinen zusammenhang mit
der preisentwicklung ev und dem neuen
euro ticket
also haben wir festgehalten dass neun
euro ticket schon tja vor allem schon
mal den geldbeutel und das hilft ja dann
möglicherweise durchaus dem einen oder
anderen bei den gestiegenen
energiepreisen und idealerweise steigen
dann auch dauerhaft mehr menschen in die
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel um das würde
dann nicht nur den geldbeutel sondern
auch dem klima helfen wie mein kollege
christian zusammengefasst hat
beim verkehr hat deutschland 2021 seine
klimaziele verfehlt
148 millionen tonnen co2 hat der
verkehrssektor laut umweltbundesamt
verursacht drei millionen mehr als
erlaubt nur energiewirtschaft und
industrie produzieren mehr treibhausgase
2030 sollen es nach dem
klimaschutzgesetz nur noch 85 millionen
tonnen sein dafür müssten die maßnahmen
deutlich verschärft werden das
umweltbundesamt empfiehlt deshalb unter
anderem noch schärfere co2 grenzwerte
für neuwagen eine e auto quote und ein
generelles tempolimit
demnach könnte eine
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung von 130 auf
autobahnen jährlich rund zwei millionen
tonnen co2 einsparen
herr wissing wann kommt das generelle
tempolimit auf deutschen autobahnen
darauf haben wir uns bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen nicht
verständigt das war keinem der
verhandlungspartner so wichtig dass es
eingang in den koalitionsvertrag
gefunden hätte wir haben uns auf
wirksamere co2 reduktions maßnahmen
verständigt und die setzen wir um es ist
natürlich wichtig dass wir die mobilität
der gesellschaft die immer im blick
haben als verkehrsminister muss ich
dafür sorgen dass die
mobilitätsbedürfnisse der bürger und
bürger
befriedigt werden das heißt jeder der
ein mobilitätsbedürfnis hat braucht
einen für ihn passende das
mobilitätsangebot und gleichzeitig
müssen wir co2 reduktion betreiben das
heißt wir müssen an vielen bereichen
hart arbeiten aber das tun wir auch mit
vielen programmen und klaren konzepten
ja das stimmt das steht nicht im
koalitionsvertrag drin aber mittlerweile
sich die zeiten ja auch ein stück weit
geändert wir sind mitten in einer
energiekrise fast zwei drittel der
deutschen sprechen sich mittlerweile für
ein tempolimit aus experten sagen wir
kommen da eh nicht drum rum warum tun
sie sich so schwer damit
nun wir wollen die verantwortung der
menschen nicht durch staatliche verbote
und vorschriften ausschalten wir wollen
dass die gesellschaft im engen
zusammenhalt und aus verantwortung
heraus die transformation zu
klimaneutraler mobilität gestaltet und
das ist eben ein freiheitlicher ansatz
und ich glaube dass der auch notwendig
ist dann schauen sie wenn wir mit zwang
mit verboten mit
[Musik]
mobilitätseinschränkungen arbeiten
würden hätte dies auch zur folge dass
der gesellschaftliche zusammenhalt
gefährdet wäre und wir brauchen ja
dauerhaft
parlamentarische mehrheiten aus der
demokratischen mitte um klimaschutz zu
betreiben ein klimaschutzprogramm mit
maximaler härte aufzulegen das nur
kurzfristig ertragen wird dann aber
abgewählt wird macht keinen sinn denn
klimaschutz ist nichts was für eine
legislaturperiode sein wir müssen
dauerhaft co2 03 werden und sie sehen
den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
gefährdet wenn zwei drittel der
deutschen sagen tempolimit wäre für mich
okay naja diese fragen nach dem
tempolimit sind ja sehr sehr
unterschiedlich mal wird nach dem
tempolimit von 130 gefragt was die
umweltverbände allerdings von mir gerne
hätten wir ein tempolimit von 100 auf
der autobahn von 80 auf der landstraße
von 30 in der innenstadt und das
kombiniert mit flächendeckender
engmaschiger geschwindigkeitskontrolle
das ist ja das was am ende dann
gefordert würde und ob das eine große
mehrheit in der bevölkerung hat das wage
ich doch sehr zu bezweifeln ich glaube
nicht dass die begeisterung sehr groß
ist mit
flächendeckenden
blitzgeräten die reihenweise die die
strafzettel in die haushalte chic nennt
zu fahren ich glaube ich dass man da
auch vielleicht zu schnell davon ausgeht
dass das auf große begeisterung stößt
und schauen sie wir haben uns ja auf dem
wesentlich
wirksamer klimaschutz maßnahmen
verständigt wir
sollten sie mal aufzählen das wäre gut
welche meinen sie genau naja wir
investieren kräftig in den aufbau einer
ladeinfrastruktur mit einem masterplan
lade-infrastruktur zwei wir sorgen dafür
dass wir flächendeckend ein schnellladen
netz bekommen wir haben investitionen in
den aufbau einer wasserstoffwirtschaft
damit wir mit wasserstoff mobil sind ich
habe jetzt gerade forschungsprojekt
mit begeisterung freigegeben ein hybrid
schiff in der binnenschiffer das mit
wasserstoff und elektroantrieb co2
neutral betrieben werden kann wir setzen
uns morgen ist eu verkehrsministerrat
setzen uns dafür ein dass mit
synthetischen kraftstoffen
beispielsweise der flugverkehr auch der
schiffsverkehr und auch im
fahrzeugverkehr co2 reduziert werden
kann das sind dinge die wir dringend
brauchen denn das ist dann wirklich
große wurf der co2 neutrale antrieb
elektrobereich auch im verbrennungsmotor
bereich mit synthetischen kraftstoffen
das heißt am ende mit diesem pfad können
wir klimaneutralität erreichen und
schauen sie ich habe beispielsweise für
600 millionen euro in diesem jahr die
den umstieg auf
batterieelektrische busse im öpnv
gefördert wir haben heute busse die
fahren 500 kilometer mit einer
batterieladung im öpnv das ist dann
nicht eine reduktion um 2 prozent
sondern das ist eine reduktion um 100
prozent co2 und darauf konzentrieren wir
uns und dabei schaffen wir es dann auch
noch dass die transformation als
fortschritt empfunden wird wenn ich
einen bus von von diesel aggregat auf
den elektroantrieb um stelle dann habe
ich 100 prozent co2 eingespart und die
bürger haben das gleiche
mobilitätsangebot wie vorher sogar noch
viel besser mit weniger lärm emissionen
und weniger
stickoxid emissionen
das ist ein attraktives klimaschutz und
mobilitätskonzept und nicht vorschriften
einschränkungen strafmandate verbote und
mobilitäts
kürzungen das glaube ich muss man eben
in den blick haben und wir sollten immer
einen breiten gesellschaftlichen konsens
im blick haben und das erreicht man eben
mit maßnahmen die die menschen am ende
als fortschritt empfinden und nicht als
einschränkung herr wissing sie müssen
los deshalb entlasse ich sie jetzt aus
diesem interview ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich und wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend ist ich danke ihnen auch
alles gute für sie
und ich denke auch ihnen und euch für
eure fragen und kommentare und wünsche
euch noch einen schönen abend bis bald